you know a lot of people ask me that and
I'm not sure I know how to respond
because uh though I was born into a
religion nearly all of us are I'm not
particularly practitioner of it I was
born Jewish and I it's not that I have
anything against it uh I've been sort of
like a freelance in all aspects of my
life and my dialogue with God has been a
private one rather than borrowing
someone else's words I remember used to
sit in the synagogue wondering why are
these prayers the one that you have to
say so God listens you know and
ultimately I just started talking on my
own and sometimes I think that maybe
everything that I write is part of that
conversation but you know there's a
couple of important responses to your
question about spirituality here one is
that I am grateful enormously grateful
for having done this book because I got
into the book feeling extremely
concerned about the fate of the planet
and now I no longer em because I what
I've learned through my research is the
planet is going to be fine life is so
indomitable it is so creative it is so
resilient that no matter how bad the
world gets hammered either by us or by
some natural disaster and this has
happened many times long before human
beings appeared on earth you know huge
volcanic eruptions that have created
enormous extinctions I mean 250 million
years ago the Permian extinction wiped
out ninety-five percent of every living
form on earth and that was due to a
volcanic eruption in what today is
Siberia that lasted about a million
years and came up right through the
carboniferous layer and you know so talk
about global warming that was pretty
intense and and then this asteroid hits
an hour
apparently and you know and yet life
comes back and eventually it took
millions of years but it got so so
successful that we got this age of
dinosaurs which was rather amazing and
then another asteroid eventually
millions of years later knocks them
about and after another huge died back
then we get the age of mammals of which
we are currently apart and you know this
has happened often I understand the
creationists who feel such reverence for
life because they there are so many
examples of how it will always find a
way and you know a seed will Lodge
despite the best efforts of the people
who maintain New York's bridges a seed
will Lodge between two steel plates and
it'll sprout and its roots will start
pushing apart the bridge stuff will
figure out a way to grow in Chernobyl or
in places we used to make nerve gas so I
feel a reverence for life and science
has never explained how life got here in
the first place or what is the spark of
life I don't try to answer that in my
book or in my life I think it's a
mystery that really what life is about
is we're supposed to deepen that mystery
not try to solve it but the other thing
about religion is that I realized that
many of my readers probably most of them
would be believers and I would have to
at least address what their religions
think about the concept of a world
without people and it turns out that to
the biggest religions on earth Islam and
Christianity believe that the world was
created for people and when we're gone
there's no more need for a world and the
world goes away so i had to at least you
know touch those bases in the book but i
had a really wonderful and unexpected
experience as a result of talking to
lots of religious leaders i realized at
one point that three of them very
different from one another
a korean buddhist monk a an evangelical
protestant leader here in the united
states and a muslim cleric a Sufi master
in Istanbul all gave me almost identical
answers they all said that yes the earth
as we know it is going to disappear
sometimes it's just going to go away and
you know after the human experience is
over I guess the Buddhists believe it's
going to come back again but but the
others you know there is an Armageddon
really and yet all three of them said
that we don't know when that's going to
happen because it's going to happen on
God's time which is a mystery to us and
anybody who presumes to know and that
that is is I mean that's pride that's
not knowledge because you know this
religion isn't about knowledge it's
about faith and while we are here just
as we should keep our bodies pure and
uncontaminated to be vessels for prayer
or we should keep our temples or
churches or mosques or synagogues
beautiful places to welcome the spirit
so we should keep this earth as lovely
as God created it to welcome God back
well you know no matter what you believe
in life whether you believe in religion
or whether you are secular atheists
humanists scientist you name it I mean
that's something that we can all get
together behind this idea that there's a
reason to preserve the planet as it is
right now because we are blessed to be a
part of it whatever that blessing comes
from I mean this is incredible that we
get to be part of this force called life
and we should nurture it rather than
stripe
you